des conteneurs remplis de plastique
kelly le malouf on en voit régulièrement
à l'étranger
on en voit aussi aux états unis mais la
plupart en asie comme comme le vietnam
comme le thaïlande comme la malaisie
comme
comme l'inde en moyenne il exporte 50
heures par semaine vers l'asie des
plastiques qui provient des commerces et
des industries
eliane couche d'adhésifs là dessus alors
on a essayé de le recycler le calme en a
pas on n'a pas réussi malheureusement
et qu'est ce que vous devez faire avec
maintenant ça s'en va à l'export p ce
stock sera chargé aujourd'hui dans un
conteneur l'an dernier le canada a
envoyé plus de 100 mille tonnes de
déchets de plastique à l'étranger à des
milliers de kilomètres d'ici
ous avons la marchandise qu'on voit ici
ça va aux philippines pour être recyclés
l'avant depuis que la chine a fermé ses
frontières les exportations canadiennes
de plastique verlaine ont augmenté de
75% vers la malaisie 2000 pour ça mais
ça demeure beaucoup moins que ce qu'on
en voyait à l'époque en chine depuis que
la chine a fermé ses portes très
difficile de savoir ce qui se passe avec
ça est ce qu'est ce qu'il est vraiment
recyclé est ce qu'on l'enfouît là bas
parce que ça coûte moins cher que de
l'emploi récit malgré tout le transport
au canada 9 % des déchets plastiques
sont recyclés 4% sont incinérés et 86 %
sont envoyés dans des sites
d'enfouissement
mais depuis que la chine a changé ses
règles de plus en plus de recycleur voit
le jour ici au québec on a la chance
d'avoir développé dhr ces plastiques là
mais effectivement d'autres provinces
canadiennes sont pris présentement avec
ses ballons ça c'est du plastique mix
donc c'est le grade numéro 3 à 7
cette matière est vendu à cohade ville
une vingtaine d'entreprises québécoises
recycle du plastique mais des centres de
tri doivent encore envoyé certains types
de plastiques dont ceux à usage unique à
l'enfouissement
quant à cali le malouf il craint que les
pays asiatiques ferment leurs portes aux
matières plastiques comme ont déjà
menacé de le faire la malaisie les
philippines
on a peur qu'un jour ils vont arrêter
c'est pour cela que nous c'est pour cela
maintenant on commence à virer de bord
pour comprendre cycle localement un
enjeu environnemental et politique
alors que les canadiens génère chaque
année plus de trois millions de tonnes
de plastique et c'est jean philippe
robillard radio canada montréal